was ist da schiefgelaufen vor allen
dingen seitens der europäischen union
und das war die antwort der kanzlerin
also ich glaube dass im großen ganzen
nichts schiefgelaufen ist und dass wir
erstens das bekommen was versprochen
wurde das war das erste resultat gestern
dann ist natürlich die frage im raum
warum sind die usa schneller
warum es israel schneller warm ist
großbritannien schneller das wohnt ein
natürlich und da muss man sehen
in großbritannien hat astrazeneca sehr
viel schneller die zulassung bekommen
an einem tag das eine note zulassung wir
haben uns entschieden dass wir das
gründlich bei der europäischen medizin
agentur machen wollen weil wir auch nein
das war kein fehler
wir sind auf das vertrauen angewiesen
und ich bin dafür dass wir das dann auch
mit der notwendigen gründlichkeit machen
zweites was immer im raum steht die
frage haben wir gestern gestellt hätten
wir mehr bezahlt könnte man mit mehr
geld mehr bekommen und die antwort war
nein denn es ist so die vereinigten
staaten von amerika haben
produktionskapazitäten pfizer ist ja
auch nen amerikanische firma und amerika
exportiert so gut wie nichts aus seinen
grenznaher aus das heißt wir als
europäer sind auf unsere
produktionsanlagen zurückgeworfen oder
angewiesen aber ist nur ein punkt noch
und da will ich nur sagen sind wir jetzt
dabei und in einem wirklich schnellen
tempo eine neue fabrik in marburg für
biotech zu eröffnen bei uns das
natürlich selbst gemacht weil die
staatlichen seiten haben in schnellster
weise die genehmigungen erteilt und
deshalb dauert es ja aber wir sind auch
eben gründlich bei der sache der
zulassung wir müssen mit unseren eigenen
produktionskapazitäten hinkommen und
deshalb glaube ich erkannte schon ein
richtiger weg und dass wir es europäisch
gemeinsam bestellt haben das ist allemal
richtig wir sind bild und wie ihr
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier und
vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren